schönen guten Morgen Bernd guten Morgen
meine Damen und Herren ja Mittwoch früh
um 9 Uhr eine Regierungserklärung das
ist äußerst selten warum ist das so nun
der Bundeskanzler muss mittagspreis nach
Brüssel da ist der
eu-asiengipfel gerade schon erwähnt und
deswegen also heute morgen diese
Regierungserklärung in den Tagen darauf
dann der EU-Gipfel und da gibt es ja
viel zu beraten nicht nur über weitere
Ukraine Hilfen und das Verhältnis zu
Ungarn und Russland sondern es geht
natürlich auch um Klima und Wirtschaft
und ausgerechnet in diesen Zeiten wo es
erstmalig geklappt hat dass der
rechtsstaatsmechanismus der EU
durchgesetzt werden kann gegen Ungarn
Stichwort Korruption Gelder werden
eingefroren ausgerechnet jetzt erlebt
die EU selber einen großen Korruptions
Skandal viel um darüber zu diskutieren
ich begrüße ganz herzlich Achim Poster
den stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden für diesen Bereich
aus der SPD und Johann davidfull für die
CDU in der gleichen Funktion gesagt der
große Skandal der sich dort entwickelt
hat seit Freitag eine
Vizepräsidentin verhaftet gestern ihres
Amtes enthoben worden eine Griechen
Sozialdemokratin was ist da los wie groß
ist der Schaden für die EU also der
Schaden ist sehr groß weil es ja immer
so ist wenn einige schwarze Schafe
kriminell aktiv sind müssen alle drunter
leiden aber die meisten Abgeordneten
fast alle Abgeordneten oder alle die ich
jedenfalls kenne sind sehr ordentlich
machen ihre Arbeit dieser Skandal zeigt
dass es hemmungslose habt ihr gibt in
Verbindung mit bandenmäßiger krimineller
Energie und deswegen ist gut dass die
bergische Justiz schnell gehandelt hat
und es ist gut dass sie viel zu
Präsidentin nicht mehr viel zu Präsident
ist sondern abgesetzt wurde mit
übergroßer Mehrheit sie sagt ja sie sei
unschuldig es geht um die
Glaubwürdigkeit der EU sagt die deutsche
Außenministerin Herr war der cool was
kann man tun mehr Compliance Regeln als
man ohnehin schon hat oder wie kann man
das Einfangen ich glaube wir können noch
100 Regelungen mehr einführen wenn
Kriminalität gibt und wenn es die
Bereitschaft gibt Abgeordnete bestechen
zu wollen und auf der anderen Seite auch
bedauerlicherweise Abgeordnete die das
entgegennehmen wollen wird das
bedauerlicherweise immer Möglichkeiten
der Umgehung geben was wir hier aber
doch feststellen ist es sind schlimme
Taten wegen derer sie verdächtigt wird
noch gilt ja die Unschuldsvermutung das
muss man auch sagen ist ja
Rechtsstaatsprinzip aber es ist auf es
ist gefunden worden es wird aufgeklärt
es sind harte Konsequenzen schnell
transparent gezogen worden das heißt wir
sind nicht wehrlos wir unterliegen einem
solchen Mechanismus nicht über eine
längere Zeit ganz offensichtlich und das
zeigt doch auch dass im Prinzip das
System funktioniert und das auch harte
und klare Konsequenzen gezogen werden
Katharina Bali Sozialdemokratien aus
Deutschland ebenfalls Parlaments Vize
sagt es war eigentlich gar keinen
Geheimnis Frau kaii hat sich immer für
Katar eingesetzt sie hat das sogar als
Teil ihr eine Agenda behandelt sie ist
dann in einen Ausschuss gegangen wo sie
gar nicht hingehörte und hat abgestimmt
was ist da los im Europa-Parlament naja
man es gibt bei uns ja auch
partnerschaftsgruppen mit verschiedenen
Ländern da gab es eben auch eine Gruppe
glaube ich für die Golfregion dass sie
sich für Katar so ausgesprochen hat wie
sie das gemacht hat das weiß ich das
wussten viele das heißt aber noch nicht
dass man davon ausgehen muss dass sie
sich ihre eigene Meinung ist sondern
dass sie das macht weil sie Geld kriegt
das ist ja das neue größere Problem das
Drittstaaten massiv versuchen jetzt im
Europäischen Parlament in der
Europäischen Union tätig zu werden und
von daher muss man dann natürlich massiv
eingreifen und noch einmal ganz kurz
innerhalb von fünf Tagen wo diese viel
zu Präsidentin aber
sozusagen nicht mehr Witze ist nicht
mehr viel zu Präsidentin sie wurde aus
der Partei ausgeschlossen sie wurde aus
der Fraktion ausgeschlossen von daher
erwartet recht es wurde schnell
gehandelt und die EU hat sehr schnell
gehandelt die rechte liga Nord in
Italien Frau locktes handelt sich darum
soziale Demokraten sind ja noch ein paar
mehr Leute
verwickelt ist das ein Thema was ich
parteipolitisch ausschlachten sollte
nein auf keinen Fall also man muss
ehrlicherweise eingestehen wir sind hier
im Deutschen Bundestag jetzt schon
andere Fälle gegeben auch meine Fraktion
ist davon betroffen gewesen da würde ich
sagen Parteipolitik da haben wir viele
andere Themengebiete über die wir beide
auch schön miteinander streiten können
dass das tun wir auch hier stehen wir
zusammen und es gibt bedauerlicherweise
immer wieder Anfälligkeiten harte
Konsequenzen müssen getroffen werden und
wir müssen natürlich genau hinschauen
gerade wenn es um das Engagement für
ehrlich gesagt problematische Staaten
wie Katar gibt zudem der kein ganz
einfaches Verhältnis haben ein
notwendiges Verhältnis auch ein
wirtschaftsverhältnis auch ein
politisches Verhältnis aber es ist
solchen Einflüssen bedauerlicherweise
ausgesetzt dann müssen wir schon etwas
genauer hinschauen es ist etwas anderes
ob es um das Verhältnis zu Katar geht
als wenn es um das Fett zu Belgien oder
Niederlande oder Dänemark geht das ist
vollkommen klar
und vielleicht macht uns das alle noch
mal etwas wacher da fällt jetzt ein
negativer Schatten auf Brüssel das ist
insofern ein bisschen schizophren als
dass der rechtsstaatsmechanismus den man
ja nachgebessert hat gerade zu greifen
beginnt Viktor Orban Frau lockzwei jetzt
auch in Ungarn aber auf der anderen
Seite musste er jetzt nachgegeben es
sind 6,3 Milliarden Euro an Geldern
eingefroren worden weitere 5,8 äh aus
dem corona-fonds und Victor Orban wie
gesagt muss jetzt reformieren denn
dieses Rechtsstaatsprinzip das hat ja
geklappt genau die Europäische Union hat
einen klares Signal gesetzt für
Rechtsstaatlichkeit für Demokratie für
Gewaltenteilung und es zeigt sich doch
sehr deutlich dass das was die
Europäische Union macht was die
Kommission macht und das Parlament dass
das funktioniert denn Herr Orban ist mit
seinem Erpressungsversuch gegenüber den
anderen EU-Ländern kläglich gescheitert
und am Schluss ist es so wie häufig im
Leben Geld ist ganz wichtig und diese
Milliarden Summen die gesperrt sind oder
eingefroren sind das ist für Orban und
seine Regierung sehr sehr schmerzhaft
und dass der einzige Grund warum er sich
bewegt hat und wir hoffen dass er sich
weiter bewegt denn die Europäische Union
wird glasklar weiter diesen klaren Kurs
verfolgt das Rechtsstaatsprinzip 2021
nachgebessert man kann jetzt auch Gelder
einfrieren mit qualifizierter Mehrheit
wird das passieren zumindest ist es
jetzt im Vorfeld schon so besprochen
dadurch fließen jetzt aber auch 18
Milliarden endlich an die Ukraine wie
wichtig ist das ja gerade voll das
Ungarn hier sein Widerstand aufgegeben
na das unheimlich wichtig möchte mal
ganz grundsätzlich sagen wir freuen uns
dass Ungarn Mitglied der Europäischen
Union ist und dann ist nicht nur die
Regierung Orban und dann ist mehr
Deutschland hat Ungarn viel zu verdanken
Wiedervereinigung wir erinnern uns und
dann war entscheidend dafür dass erste
DDR Bürger auch in den Westen konnten
noch Österreich fliegen konnten also das
sollte man alles nicht vergessen aber es
ist ein ständiges Ring wir haben klare
Prinzipien post vollkommen zu wir
brauchen jetzt ungern auch wir müssen
auch ungern insgesamt sagen du musst
auch im Team spielen wenn du in der
Europäischen Union eine gute Zukunft
haben willst dass unser Interesse und
dieses Teamplay muss Ungarn wieder
lernen das hat es in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten schon beherrscht und
natürlich gerade für die Ukraine ist es
von besonderer Wichtigkeit weil
natürlich das Schicksal der Ukraine
jetzt nicht nur militärisch sondern auch
mittelfristig
gesellschaftspolitisch
wirtschaftspolitisch und sozialpolitisch
dass das alles wieder gelingt in der
Ukraine dass da dass das Land wieder
aufgebaut werden kann das ist jetzt
durchhält in dieser schwierigen
Kriegszeit das ist ja für Europa
insgesamt von entscheidender Bedeutung
dafür dass unser Prinzip von
Selbstbestimmungsrecht Freiheit
Souveränität der einzelnen Staaten dass
sich das durchsetzt gegen so einen
aggressiv Russland das ist von großer
Wichtigkeit und das spielt die
Europäische Union eine entscheidende
Rolle
die Polen reagieren auch sie wegen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit da sind Gelder auch
oder drohen gefroren zu werden sagen es
so sie wollen jetzt ein neues Gesetz
verabschieden man sieht dass solche
Mechanismen greifen das ist ja die
Diskussion die auch der Bundeskanzler
schon seit geraumer Zeit führt die nicht
neues in der EU aber eine
schlachtkräftigere Union zum Beispiel
eben die Abstimmung mit qualifizierten
Mehrheiten man fragt sich auf der
anderen Seite Bosnien-Herzegowina jetzt
soll aufgenommen werden als Zehnter
Start der auf einem Mitgliedschaft
hoffen darf man fragt sich wie schnell
muss ich die EU reformieren damit sie so
viele neue Mitglieder eines Tages dann
auch in ihren Reihen begrüßen kann die
EU muss ich schneller reformieren weil
das gehört zusammen Vertiefung und
Erweiterung wir sind jetzt ungefähr fast
auf den Tag genau 20 Jahren nach der
wirklich letzten großen
Erweiterungsrunde um zehn Staaten nach
dem Kopenhagen da Gipfel jetzt steht
hier Erweiterung um die Länder des
westlichen Wahlkampfs an es darf aber
keine Rabatte geben sondern die
Kopenhagener Kriterien vor 20 Jahren
beschlossen wurden müssen weiter Geld
gelten und es gilt Demokratie
Rechtsstaat Gewaltenteilung
Pressefreiheit soziale Marktwirtschaft
also alles harte Kriterien wo man nicht
sagen kann naja wir wollen ja mit dabei
haben die sollen jetzt mal mitmachen
sondern da sind wir uns auch völlig
einig in Deutschland aber auch in der
Europäischen Union die Kriterien müssen
gelten und die Kriterien werden gelten
so ein Beitritt dauert ja ziemlich lange
die Ukraine gehört auch dazu in der
Hoffnung aber das wird demnächst mal
nutzen gestern gab es in Paris eine
Geberkonferenz eine Milliarde damit man
jetzt auch direkt helfen kann zum
Beispiel was die Kälte und den Winter
angeht in der Ukraine die brauchen jeden
Cent sage ich mal und es gibt ja viel
Geld was gesammelt wird was äh
transferiert wird
wie wird das eigentlich koordiniert die
G7 hat jetzt gerade so eine neue
Plattform beschlossen wäre das eine
Möglichkeit das Geld tatsächlich
gerichtet dazu transformieren na ich
glaube wir brauchen mehrere Plattformen
wir brauchen auch verschiedene Ebenen
Möglichkeiten das Geld sag mal ganz
pragmatisch ein zusammen und es dann
natürlich auch zu verteilen dass das
irgendwo koordiniert werden soll das
glaube ich auch aber ich glaube weder
Europa kann das alleine schaffen noch
die G7 sondern es müssen viele viele
jetzt hier helfen und wir haben ja
eigentlich gemerkt auch bei den
Abstimmungen in den Vereinten Nationen
die Solidarität am Ende mit der Ukraine
ist auf der ganzen Welt schon sehr groß
weil viele merken wenn wir Russland das
durchgehen lassen wenn Russland an
dieser Stelle Erfolg hätte dann kann das
auch uns betreffen dann kann das auch
unsere Region betreffen dann kann das
auch in auf unserem Kontinent bedeuten
dass Grenzen verschoben werden können
und das einfach eine Aggressionskrieg
geführt werden kann und deswegen bin ich
ganz zuversichtlich dass da mehr gelingt
Deutschland geht hier voran das begrüßen
wir auch als Opposition
Außenministerin war gestern in Paris
dabei
besteht Deutschland gut an der Stelle
auch eine Führungsrolle zu übernehmen
und das einfach auch die Verantwortung
die wir auf diesem Kontinent haben keine
neue Botschafter hier in Berlin hat den
Bundeskanzler gerade gelobt dass sie
diese Führungsrolle auch bei G7 zum
Beispiel übernommen hat aber viele
kritisieren vor allen Dingen auch in den
eigenen Ampel Fraktionen dass
Deutschland eben genau in dem wichtigen
Bereich Militärhilfe versagt 4,3
Milliarden haben wir schon über diesen
viele viele Waffen hingegeben aber die
Waffen die gebraucht werden nämlich der
Leopard 2 zum Beispiel oder der Marder
die auch zur Verfügung stehen die wollen
die FDP liefern die wollen die Grünen
liefern viele Europäer fordern dass die
Opposition auch warum die SPD an dieser
Stelle so zurückhaltend dass die Grünen
das fordern oder die FDP weiß ich nicht
es sind ja meist einzelne das liegt in
der Natur der Sache wenn ich einen
historisches Ereignis habe wie Putins
Aggression gegen die Ukraine dass man
sich darüber unterhält auf der Strecke
was man leisten kann ich finde das
Deutschland sehr sehr viel leistet nicht
nur im humanitären Bereich nicht nur bei
den Flüchtlingen sondern auch
militärisch das ist ja für uns eine
Situation die ziemlich neu ist dass wir
in dem Ausmaß Waffen liefern das haben
wir noch nie gemacht und wir werden
alles weiter tun damit wir die Ukraine
auch militärisch helfen vor allen Dingen
im Verbund mit unseren europäischen und
amerikanischen verbündet ich weiß es
fällt auf dass auch im Sommer bei
schweren Waffen Deutschland zu spät dran
war und noch mal der Eindruck jetzt
Panzer die bei diesem Wetter auch
geeignet und wenn man immer schon das
Wort im Munde führt dass in der Ukraine
auch sich das Schicksal Europas der
westlichen Welt entscheidet dann ist es
doch unverständlich warum Deutschland da
nicht tätig wird ja wir kritisieren das
ja seit mehreren Monaten und der Staat
sind des Bundeskanzlers ist einfach
nicht nachvollziehbar mittlerweile haben
wir auch die Amerikaner gesagt das ist
eine deutsche Entscheidung das zu machen
oder nicht zu machen also dieses
verstecken hinter einer vermeintlichen
Entscheidung die auf NATO Ebene oder mit
unseren Verbündeten getroffen worden
wäre das Kartenhaus
ist zusammengebrochen also
es ist richtig es gibt keine formalen
Beschlüsse von von von Grünen und von
FDP aber die ganz über große Mehrheit
der verteilungs- und
Sicherheitspolitiker bei der Fraktionen
wie die cdu/csu haben die Erwartungen
ganz klar geäußert an den Bundeskanzler
sich hier zu bewegen
so wir gehen auf Weihnachten zu das ist
ja auch ein Fest der Hoffnung
möglicherweise bewegt er sich noch es
wird sicherlich auch hier Thema heute in
der in der Debatte sein aber man muss
einfach ganz nüchtern sagen das ist
unterlassene Hilfe Leistung und deswegen
ist Olaf Scholz wirklich gefordert sich
noch zu bewegen Prost die Zeit läuft uns
weg aber der Kanzler wird sicherlich
auch eine Bilanz des ersten Jahres
ziehen auch Europa politisch und da
sagen ja viele Kritiker das ist
eigentlich gar nicht so gut gelungen
denn die deutsch-französische Achse die
Leier da läuft's nicht richtig und wenn
man jetzt bei der Gaspreis Bremse sieht
die deutschen stehen in Europa da auf
der Bremse dann sind doch viele Europäer
sehr vergrenzt gegenüber den Deutschen
naja also ich will erstmal sagen dass
der Begriff Stahl sind für den
Bundeskanzler glaube ich der falsche
Begriff ist der handelt sehr besonnen
und im Verbund mit unseren Partnern in
Nordamerika und in Europa das Punkt eins
Punkt zwei noch nie zuvor das kann ich
wirklich beurteilen wie jetzt hat die
Europäische Union hat Europa in
energiepolitischen Fragen so eng
zusammengearbeitet wie jetzt das ist da
an der ein oder anderen alle noch nicht
sofort zu Beschlüssen kommt das liegt in
der Natur der Sache der nächste
energieministerrat ist Montag der Gipfel
ist jetzt morgen und übermorgen also es
gibt viele Möglichkeiten in den nächsten
Tagen weiter zusammenzukommen
deutsch-französische Zusammenarbeit wir
haben aufgelöst die lange verhaken
zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich bei
der Entwicklung des neuen bombersystems
kampfjet-systems FKS von daher es geht
voran auch mit den deutsch-französischen
Beziehungen aber sie humpeln ein
bisschen und vor allen Dingen der
französische Präsident man hat so ein
bisschen das Gefühl er ist derjenige der
in Europa den Takt vorgibt aber auch
nicht immer in der Richtung die ihnen
gefällt er gerade voll denn er hat ja
z.B gesagt es muss der Perspektiven für
Russland geben Verhandlungen etc das
haben sie auch massiv kritisiert ja weil
das vollkommen verkehrt ist jetzt
Russland zu sagen dass dessen
Sicherheitsinteressen geschützt werden
müssen die ukrainischen müssen geschützt
werden Russland gefährlich die sicher
der Ukraine und die Sicherheit Europas
das heißt da das muss von dem Kopf auf
die Füße wieder gestellt werden und
insofern hat der Bundeskanzler hier eine
große Aufgabe die Achse Paris Berlin ist
vital für Europa darum muss er sich
endlich kümmern eine große Aufgabe fürs
nächste Jahr er war dafür Herr Post
vielen Dank dass sie da waren